الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انشا
لجنه اسماها
تمتلكهم مهمتها الاساسيه حسب ما فهمنا
تعطيل اي خط بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والصين هل السبب برايك يتعلق
بالامن القومي الامريكي او بعدم السماح
لهون كونج بان تصبح القوه الماليه الاكبر
في العالم
لا اعرف ما اذا كان لي فريق تمتلكم
نيه تتعلق بهم كونغ اعرف ان هذا الفريق
شكله دونالد ترامب في خضم جدالهم عاصين
وخاصه بشان تكنولوجيا المعلومات
والتطبيقات والذكاء وكل الشؤون الرقميه
لكن يمكنني ان اقول لك بكل ثقه ان الضرر
الذي لحق عده شركات امريكيه جاءها من
شركات الاتصال الامريكيه اكثر لا من
نظيراتها الصينيه وانها هي التي كانت عرضه
لانقطاعات اكثر من الشركات الاسيويه
مؤخرا لاحظنا انه روسيا حولت مسار حركه
الانترنت في منطقه خيرسون الاوكرانيه التي
تسيطر عليها عسكريا بحيث تم قطعها بشكل
كامل عن الشبكه المركزيه الانترنت في
اوكرانيا وربطها عبر بنيتها التحتيه
للاتصالات هل يمكن ان نشاهد مثل هذه
القرارات تمتد الى دول اخرى
هذا ما قلته وهو دليل على ضروره ان تتعامل
الدول مع هذا الميدان من مقاربه حيويه
وكيف يمكنها ضمان الانترنت لمواطنينها في
كل الظروف والاوقات العصيبه مثل الحرب
الروسيه
بينطبق هذا على على اوروبا بينطبق على
الهند بقيه الدول بقيه الدول العالم الصين
مثلا
نعم وفي الواقع فان الاتحاد الاوروبي على
معرفه دقيقه بهذه الملفات ويعمل على تغيير
مناهجه بشانها وحكوماتها تنخرط في انشاء
الكابلات لقد باتت تمنح تمويلات بملايين
الدولارات لمقاولين من مواطنيها وتبني
شركات لضمان ان يكون لكل دوله اوروبيه جزء
في خطوط الكابلات بما يضمن الانترنت
وسيادتها على الخطوط
البعض يتساءل عن دور الاتفاقيات القانونيه
والدوليه مثل اتفاقيه الامم المتحده
لقانون البحار هل هي عاجزه تماما ايذاء
هذا
هذه السيطره على الكبلات البحريه
في الختام هل من نصيحه للحكومات
لمواجهه اي تعطيل في خدمه الانترنت مواجهه
هذه المعضله العالميه
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه يتعين على كل دوله وحكومه ان
تقوم بعمليه تدقيق ومراجعه واسعه لوضع
الانترنت لديها وبناء برامج جديده تضمن
لها الاعتماد الذاتي والضمانات الكافيه
والبنيه الضروريه الملائمه مثل الذي تم
اطلاقه في الهند مؤخرا تحت شعار الهند
المعتمده على الذات يؤمن ذلك البرنامج
للهند التحكم في مصيرها ومصير سكانها
الرقمي مهما كانت الظروف الدوليه وحتى
الداخليه التي تمر بها وبالمثل ينبغي على
كل دوله ان تحذوها هذا المثال بما يضمن
لها في حال اي طارئ قيامها بالمطلوب منها
من مهام اداريه وايضا ان تجهز نفسها
بالتشريعات وايضا ماليا ما يجعل مواطنيها
قادرين على العمل بالانترنت تحت اي ظرف